can I get to the serious question to
start off here Aaron
good morning by the way yeah okay do you
shovel your own snow sometimes yes
sometimes you have to I've done that
many times I got my truck stuck over the
years issue is when the the the plows
come through the streets they can throw
a bunch of snow in your driveway and if
you got a truck and you feel like you
can four-wheel drive over that snow
sometimes get stuck so got my truck
stuck a couple times and definitely been
out there shoveling the the front drive
drive away multiple times before the
before the crews get over to help you
out do you why this is breaking news a
lot of doubters alright yeah a lot of
doubters now I didn't know if you'd have
a snow blower the consensus with the
dance was you have a snow blower I don't
[Music]
they don't volunteer to help you know I
will give credit my my neighbor across
the street at my old house he would he
would help me out all right that's all
we wanted to know Aaron okay
make me Anya how surprised are you with
what's happened here in the last six
weeks eight weeks with just overall
performance and your individual
performance
I wouldn't say surprised I'm uh I'm
really happy about the way that we
responded after a really tough stretch
in middle of season but but now I'm not
surprised I always believe in myself and
and my teammates and although when you
when you say something like run the
table you're taking a leap of faith
because you're obviously in a rut at the
time but I just believe that if we could
get that first when things get going and
and who knows how long we could stay on
the run how did you get into a rut well
I wouldn't blame I wasn't playing great
and we weren't playing complete games as
a team and in all three phases and when
you put those two together you're not
going to win
games in this league so you've lost a
couple tight ones we got blown out you
know a couple times as well so we kind
of went back in the locker room and you
know just started communicating a little
better with our with our teammates and
and just kind of bought in again and
refocused and got things going but
something had to click where it just it
just felt like it was the way it was
supposed to be to start this season I
what was there a moment where you just
said or a game where you just said okay
this is who we are well offensively it
was the washing game which was the end
of the four-game losing streak I just
felt like our offense was finally
getting to a place where we could be
dangerous
Jared Cook came back had a big game that
night and started to look more like what
we thought we're gonna look early in the
season we respond to the next week in
Philly and had a very nice offensive
performance and that started the run for
us but we we felt offensively that we
could take some pressure off the defense
if we start a little bit faster we were
starting really slow washing game three
three announced to start the game and
and Tennessee game we're down 21 nothing
you know didn't help our defense out and
we thought if we just started a little
bit faster it's gonna give our defense
confidence that they don't have to you
know get a stop every single possession
because they're often it's gonna pick
them up and then you start slow against
the Giants what are you thinking when
you're looking at this and it's three
and out and three and out and all of a
sudden the Giants have a chance to open
this up a little bit I'm thinking it
can't get any worse on offense you go
there early early on but but they got a
great defense the key for us was was our
own defense I mean we got stops we held
them the fill goes in the red zone if
it's 14 nothing there instead of six
nothing it's a whole different ballgame
but six nothing you know we're a
touchdown away from retaking the lead
and obviously changed the momentum and
then we get a big stop with it when
they're backed up a nice punt return and
next thing you know we're in a 38 yard
line going in get a touchdown they're up
by one and get a Hail Mary and you know
next thing you know we're a couple
scores and pulling away can you teach
your style could you teach your style to
somebody
I think so
I think if you look at look at some of
my backups over the years and the way
that they you know adapt and change
their mechanics and fundamentals
slightly with their drops and their arm
angles and their movements I think you
see some similarities for sure but the
great thing about this game is everybody
has their own style and can do it in
their own way but mine's a little
obviously a little unique and different
than in the next guys but when you were
coming out of college people weren't
sure if you'd be the number one pick or
not and of course you weren't but what
what were they missing when they were
assessing your talents that we now look
at it and say you know you're a Hall of
Fame quarterback but what what was
absent there I think it's the things
that you can't measure with you know
with the tape measure or you know get a
specific number for as in height weight
and 42 time and Wonderlic score and
these things you can't measure the
mental and physical toughness you can't
measure you know you can't really get a
feel for how memorization and
visualization and preparation can put a
player in a position to be prepared on
Sunday to go out and and and execute and
dominate yeah you can look at film and
and try and project and talk about you
know ball carriage and footwork and and
those fundamentals but but but you can't
you can't project how a person deals
with adversity and once they start to
become a starter how they deal with
frustration how they deal with critics
how they deal with all the things that
come at a quarterback how they can lead
in a locker room when things are going
great where things are going
rough and those are things that I've
always felt like I've allowed me to
separate from from some of my peers he's
Aaron Rodgers he's got the Cowboys
coming up on Sunday Jordy Nelson status
what do you know now I just know what
everybody else knows I saw him last
night for a little bit
Payne but he's going to be around this
week and see see how it feels later in
the week and then make a decision at
that point can you wear protective
padding there that would allow him to
play uh you know we were talking last
night I think he brought up when when
Vic got his ribs banged up and he was
wearing some sort of Kevlar vest that
allowed him to play so I know there's
stuff out there I'm sure that the team
is looking into that or people are
sending it on their own their own their
own methods and when I you know when I
hurt my calf or where various injures
I've had over the years you know our fan
base is pretty incredible when it comes
to their abilities to to treat injuries
they all have their own ideas about what
specific types of medicine or remedies
you got a home remedies there by the
Packer fans yeah they got their own
stuff out there so pretty amazing what
is the play called
on the Hail Mary the actual play it it's
called a rebound pass that's it yeah
so you go into the huddle and you go
rebound a pass onto yeah I don't know
wouldn't go on two on that one but okay
but yeah that's it how often do you
practice that how do you practice that
well we do that in a in a drill usually
on a Saturday practice or the end of a
Thursday practice and it's against the
defense it's slightly competitive we're
not trying to get anybody to jump on
anybody's ankles or or hurt anybody in
the endzone but we more more work on the
mechanics of getting to the spot where
you can get the ball out and then how we
want guys platooned in the end zone and
what their responsibilities are you know
played out exactly how you how you
practicing you got a jumper you get a
guy in front you got a guy behind and
Randall was aware enough to make a play
on you know on both the ones that that
we've scored on - the janus one you know
we had
we had to Vontae in there kind of mixing
things up but the first time he kind of
set the depth a little deep in Detroit
and rich was able to kind of mosey down
in there and make the play as everybody
kind of misjudged the ball and it's kind
of the same thing here is the kind of
the pack if you will was was kind of
between 3 & 7 yards deep and Randall was
able to sneak back in there in the back
of the end zone so that the tough thing
I think for both the offense and defense
at times is with the trajectory of the
football it does make it hard to the
judge sometimes when that where that
ball is coming down but you also keep it
in play I find so many of these guys who
throw a pass and then they don't keep it
in bounds it at least you're throwing it
up and down the chimney and you know
your guy has a chance to make the play
and if are tougher to try to battle ball
down I think when it's coming straight
down as opposed to a little bit more on
an angle that's exactly why we do it
buddy yeah that's that just mean I'm
just chaining I took that that's a good
term there Dan that's exactly how we say
it acts oh you do yeah we do well I
played quarterback my freshman year in
high school so I think we have something
in common we do yeah did you watch the
football game last night
I did I was fantastic absolutely but
what do you watch footing can you just
watch as a fan and just you know sit
there and have a beer and popcorn and
watch it like anybody else for sure but
I'm always interested in quarterback
play and you know kissing Alabama had a
couple of great drives there late in the
game but but the shine Watson is an
electric player and yes it's a great
story he is played phenomenal in both
sister 'national championship games what
a player on the fun to watch that guy
and great way to go out there with a
touchdown with a second left and a great
drive and win a national championship
it's almost like they hit harder in
college than they do the pros how come
it just it feels like they give them
more freedom to hit harder and less
calls and they you know they were
hitting him up high they're hitting him
in the head you know early Alabama was
just bringing you know everything to
anyone who had a ball and it feels like
you can do
more in college than you can the pros I
don't know maybe it was just the game
last night it was that was pretty
violent game last night well yeah I
would mmm I would only disagree with you
on this point that you know I don't know
you feel about it but at the target II
rule to me is is a little out of balance
right now do you like it a punishment it
doesn't seem like it it fits the the
penalty to kick a guy out of the game
for a hit this you know we're making it
tough on defenders with with target
areas and for college you know to kick a
guy out on a on a play that's uh you
know it's a judgment it's a judgment
call on whether or not he you know
intended or didn't intend to and I think
it needs to be a little more subjective
ultimately because if a receiver
last-minute ducks and the target was
chest yeah guys gonna hit in the head
and then that players out of the game
and if it happens in the second half and
he's out of that game and then out of
the first half of the next game I just
don't think that's way too big of a
penalty for a guy who you know may or
may not have been trying to target a
player and the way that these coaches
are coaching them I would tend to lean
that he's not intentionally trying to
target a guy in the head or neck area
but receiver may flinch or duck or move
at the last second and a hit that's in a
normal target in a normal target area
turns into be a hit to the head so but I
felt like the ruffian last night was
very solid because there were some some
shots to the head or neck area but but
they weren't defensive defensive players
do you have a problem with the NFL
brought in targeting if they kick the
eye of the game I think I think letting
them be ridiculous just keep it the way
it is we get fined yeah I don't but
that's a big deterrent have you ever
been fined no still waiting on my first
one we came up but we made a shirt out
of what you said with you know that you
said to relax we're thinking of a new
shirt this year for the playoffs shovel
your own snow and it's just we'll do it
in packer colors do I have permission do
I have sign off on and you know we
share all the money charity shovel your
own sue what do you think yeah I love it
I love it dan what are you gonna what
are you to put on the front picture
maybe a like a silhouette of you
shoveling hmm yeah
nobody gloves on because there's
multiple times I'd be out there and I
didn't have gloves
that was my acclimation to the cold
weather that I've played well over the
years and cold weather you're a badass
man yeah no gloves hey Congrats good
luck in Dallas thanks for joining us
here all right Dan thanks all right
that's Aaron Rodgers Packers quarterback
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]